bonsoir les images que vous découvrez en
même temps que nous c'est en direct de
la rue des rosiers ou vous savez ce midi
un attentat a provoqué la mort de six
personnes est de 12 et fait douze
blessés
c'est l'arrivée du président de la
république que nous tentons de vous
montrer actuellement vous voyez le
déploiement de forces car il y à
quelques minutes il ya eu une
manifestation spontanée
il ya notamment françois mitterrand
complice de cet attentat
journaliste assassin il faut dire que
l'atmosphère sur place rue des rosiers
et très tendue voire très agressive à
l'égard des représentants de la presse à
l'égard des policiers
un policier a été blessé récemment on
attend donc l'apparition du président
françois mitterrand qui avait souhaité
se rendre
un office religieux dans une synagogue
ce soir à paris il semble donc que le
président de la république ait pu venir
très rapidement
rue des rosiers bonsoir six morts 12
blessés 22 mois après l'attentât de la
rue copernic contre une synagogue des
hommes et des femmes ont été tuées dans
une rue de paris dans le 4e
arrondissement dans la rue des rosiers
sept quartiers juifs attentats
antisémites dont voici les premières
images rapportées par nos équipes
il était alors un peu plus de 13 heures
il est environ 13 heures 15 quand un
commando de deux ou quatre hommes
ouvrent le feu avec des armes
automatiques des pistolets mitrailleurs
rue des rosiers les premiers témoignages
divergent ne peut pas encore dire
combien il était exactement
apparemment leur principale cible est le
célèbre restaurant israélite goldenberg
situé au 7 de cette poule avant de
pénétrer dans l'établissement il lance
une grenade à travers une des fenêtres
puis il mitraille ensuite à l'intérieur
tuant au moins trois personnes et en en
blessant plusieurs autres
c'est évidemment la panique à
l'extérieur juste devant au volant de sa
voiture un homme et blessé d'une balle
dans l'oreille de retour de l'hôpital
il témoigne j'étais assise à la voiture
au premier coup de feu bon ben je me
suis aplatit j'ai couvert mon fils qui
se trouvait à côté de moi j'ai attendu
que ça se passe ce qui m'a évité de voir
tout ce qui se passait parce que
les coups des coups de feu deux coups de
fusil ou de mitraillette ou de bâle qui
claquait m'empêcher de me lever et de
voir tous les les personnes qui tiraient
quoi ensuite le commando s'enfuit par le
dédale des petites rues adjacentes en
continuant de tirer tuant ou blessant
encore sur son passage dans la confusion
le fils du restaurateur goldenberg a
d'ailleurs blessé d'un coup de fusil de
chasse
un policier en civil qui arrivait en
cours en le prenant pour un des membres
du commando
au total cette fusillade qui n'aura duré
que quelques minutes
or a fait six morts et 22 blessés dont
neuf grièvement
il était un peu plus de 18h30 lorsque au
journal france soir une voix d'homme
enregistré sur bande magnétique a
déclaré nous sommes le groupe action
directe nous revendiquons l'attentât de
la rue des rosiers
mais quelques minutes plus tard un autre
correspondant anonyme démentait que
cette action était perpétré par des gens
d'action directe
donc pour l'instant l'attentât n'a pas
été fermement revendique alors tentons
maintenant à l'aide de ce plan du
quartier de la rue des rosiers de
reconstituer chronologiquement ce qui
s'est passé en écoutant les différents
témoignages recueillis quelques minutes
après le drame
ici au 6 de la rue pavée une femme a vu
les sommes prêts semblement les
meurtriers arriver il est 13 heures 20
j'étais à la maison on a entendu des
coups de feu et des gens courir à partir
de la rue pavée juste plus loin il ya
une synagogue et ensuite ils sont partis
en courant dans la rue
la rue des rosiers au 5 de la rue des
rosiers dans cette boucherie les
bouchers voit également passer les mêmes
hommes
le gars qui tirait il avait un costume
gris que j'ai bien vu avec une livrée
hier sous sa b2 il tirait sur tout le
monde les jeunes chez les jeunes c'est
déjà notre maroc 25 80 quand on a vu
d'ici sûrement parce que j'étais juste
en face de nous les jeunes nous parce
que ces tribunes et mercredi à jeudi
aurait un carnac au 7 de la rue des
rosiers troisième témoignage celui du
garçon du restaurant goldenberg sans
doute la cible privilégiée des
meurtriers monsieur den berg avait été
menacé de mort la gêne d'une grenade et
d aider et des coups de feu et elle
était éloignée la grenade éclaté d'abord
et les concurrents sont d'abord là la
grenade et après les et les
les côtés et ça ressemble à quoi comme
coups de feu et une mitraillette
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en ce moment
là il ya des gens qui sont tombés les
les terroristes visaient des personnes
bien noté le noir ou en face du
restaurant golden bear de l'autre côté
du trottoir
voici maintenant témoignage d'un passant
moi j'ai vu cas d'alexis millette
ils sont descendus d'un vampire je me
suis cachée
l'important est qu'elles qui voyait
éclairer sur les gens alors au 12 de
cette rue des rosiers un petit peu plus
loin une femme en face d'un marchand de
sandwichs tunisien cette femme témoigne
à son tour pour trouver un refuge les
plus vieux magasin ils m'ont tout le
monde est rentré là on est dans la
confusion un jeune homme qui tirait
maintenant parce qu' on essaie de voir
deux va tout faire pour se réfléchit on
parle et qu'on n'avait pas envie de voir
le diable et puis celle refuse qu'on a
trouvé c'était cette grande forme si
elle avait pu faire les comptes ni à
l'endroit enfin dans cette charcuterie à
l'angle de la rue des rosiers de la rue
saint-gervais deux clients de cette
charcuterie ont vu s'enfuir les mêmes
hommes après leurs attentats
vous avez donc vu oui j'ai dix derrière
wi2wi prévue demain avec des gants sacs
noirs et limitera y être dévasté gay gré
ils dépendent pas de calais français ils
étaient habillés avec des costumes louis
bien avant il fallait une couleur une
veste mauve est clair qu est ce qu on
fait comme la voix il avec éloge environ
être 24 ans au nom de l'enfant du plan
20 ans était très jeune
les meurtriers auraient alors continuer
leur route vers la rue vieille du temple
et là nous avons inscrit cette drogue
pouvait voir sur le plan les policiers
devaient découvrir un chargeur de
pistolet mitrailleur les deux tireurs
meurtrier profitait de l'affolement et
de la terreur pour s'enfuir rue des
rosiers c'était alors un spectacle
terrifiant de sang de cris d'hystérie
de nombreuses forces de police ont
rapidement cerné le quartier mais en
vain les blessés les plus graves étaient
soignés sur place avant d'être
transportées dans les hôpitaux proches
très vite les voisins les habitants du
quartier des juifs pour la plupart
arrivés sur les lieux pour antennes de
isabelle bechler vous étiez sur place
quelle fut alors qu'elle est encore
l'atmosphère oui bien tout l'après-midi
depuis 13h30 le quartier de la rue des
rosiers vous vous en doutez le quartier
était vraiment consterné les habitants
du quartier bien sûr les membres de la
communauté juive mais aussi des badauds
des parisiens venus de tous horizons
souvent en simple curieux mais très très
souvent également des gens réellement
atterré par la violence de l'attentât
mais sur place tout l'après midi
limite de ce quartier bouclé par la
police était surtout une grande tension
qui règne à une tension qui ne se dément
toujours pas d'ailleurs les d'israélites
surtout faisait évidemment le parallèle
avec la guerre israélo palestinienne au
liban et les réactions étaient des plus
vives à l'égard à l'égard de la presse
des incidents émaillés tout l'après midi
entre les badauds et les journalistes et
journalistes qui étaient présents vous
allez voir quelques extraits de ces non
pas échauffourées mais des incidents
quand même très nette
oui mes yeux
du coup
d'autres réactions une forme de skull
and je crois isabelle à l'arrivée de
monsieur de faire et puis quelques cris
hostiles à l'arrivée du président de la
république
oui c'est cela à l'instant à un membre
des gardiens de la paix a même été
apparemment légèrement blessé à
l'arrivée de monsieur de faire car on
entendait des slogans extrêmement
violent contre le gouvernement des
slogans mitterrand assassin mitterrand
complice journaliste assassin il ya eu
un petit mouvement de foule tout à
l'heure à l'arrivée des ministres de
l'intérieur et de la décentralisation
vous m'avez mayrand trahison aussi était
un slogan qui revenait souvent et tout
précédemment à l'arrivée du président
mitterrand y à peu près de cinq mille
5000 isabelle vous même vous avez eu des
difficultés je crois avec les forces de
police
oui les forces de l'ordre étaient
également tout à fait
à craon dirons nous il est assez
difficile de négocier de faire son
travail dans ce quartier complètement
bouclée par l'amo lyon et vous allez
voir quelques quelques mésaventures qui
ne sont arrivés alors qu'il s'agissait
pour moi simplement de me rendre à
l'endroit où je vais retrouver mon
équipe pour rendre compte de l'arrivée
de françois mitterrand et de l'ambiance
de l'ambiance dans la rue des rosiers
c'est sans commentaire
c'est effectivement sans commentaire
merci isabelle nous reviendrons un peu
plus avant dans ce journal avec d'un art
benyamine sursis réactions hostiles à
l'égard de la presse notamment à l'égard
de la télévision ce nouvel attentat
antisémite le plus meurtrier que la
france ait connu vient donc s'ajouter à
une liste dramatique
patricia kaas rappelle maintenant cette
succession d'actes de violence qui à
chaque fois ont fait des morts et des
blessés le 27 mars 1979 à paris une
bombe explose dans un foyer israélite 33
blessés
l'attentât a été revendiqué par un
collectif autonome le lendemain du
traité de paix entre israël et l'egypte
envers le 27 juillet 80 un homme lance
de grenade contre un groupe de jeunes
juifs orthodoxes qui partait en colonie
de vacances
un mort 20 blessés l'auteur de
l'attentât s'est réclamé d'un mouvement
palestinien exclu de l'ol paie 26
septembre 1981 apparaît une crèche juive
qui accueille des enfants de toutes
confessions et criblé de 15 impacts de
balles pas de blessé ce jour-là une
école une synagogue sont aussi visés
l'attentât est revendiqué par la fan un
mouvement d'extrême droite
le 3 octobre 1980 c'est l'attentât de la
rue copernic quatre morts et neuf
blessés
des passants essentiellement une moto
piégée explose à la porte d'une
synagogue où 200 fidèles assistaient à
l'office
on ignore toujours aujourd'hui qui est à
l'origine de cet attentat
29 août 80 à vienne en autriche trois
hommes lancent deux grenades à la porte
d'une synagogue encore au moment d'un
office deux morts et 17 blessés
l'attentât a été revendiqué par le
groupe palestinien dabo finale exclu par
l'ol paie peu de temps après sa création
en 74 20 octobre 81 à anvers en belgique
deuxième attentat dans cette ville dans
le quartier des diamantaires une voiture
piégée et quatre près d'une synagogue
trois morts et 106 blessés
l'attentât est revendiqué par le groupe
action directe en belgique
alors faut-il préciser que la
condamnation de cet attentat est unanime
en france et à l'étranger
bien sûr la communauté juive a réagi la
première et je vous propose d'écouter
tout de suite la réaction du rabbin
goldman réactions recueillies par sylvie
marion pour antenne 2 toute la
communauté est profondément attristé
touché par ce qui vient de se produire
cet après midi pour ma part je dirais
que nous pensions à juste titre que
quelques quarante ans après les
premières rafles des grande rafle du vel
d'hiv qui précisément se sont produites
en juillet 42 nous pensions que des
actes de violence ne pourrait plus se
produire de cette façon nous les
condamnons fermement violemment d'où
qu'elles viennent ces actions sont
répréhensibles
nous voyons bien qu'il y a actuellement
un amalgame qui se fait entre les
tragiques événements du moyen-orient et
des individus profitant de cette
situation confuse viennent sur le sol
français pour lancer leurs actions dans
différentes directions
bien entendu c'est avant tout la
communauté juive tout entière qui est
visé mais nous nous inclinons
profondément devant toutes les victimes
même quand il ne s'agit pas d' événement
avant directement nos institutions
avez vous un message particulier à
apporter à ceux qui dans leur colère
réclament déjà vengeance
le judaïsme n'a jamais été favorable à
la défense
nous condamnons la vengeance nous
voulons simplement la justice
nous voulons que les droits de l'homme
soient respectés
c'est une constante du judaïsme
quand il ya hélas des événements qui
contredisent cette constante nous le
déplorons également le grand rabbin de
france monsieur rené samuel sirat s'est
déclarée bouleversée dans une interview
à une radio israélienne puisqu'il se
trouve à jérusalem en ce moment je suis
bouleversé on assassine des innocents
dans les rues de paris
nous sommes entrés dans un temps où la
vie humaine ne vaut plus rien cette
atroce le grand rabbin a annoncé son
retour à paris dès demain matin
à paris le chef du bureau de l'ol paie
l'organisation de libération de la
palestine monsieur ibrahim sousse a
fermement condamné l'attentât
l'ol paix déplore les victimes
innocentes et transmet ses condoléances
à leur famille monsieur ibrahim sousse
dont l'adjoint a été assassiné il ya
quelques semaines à paris rappelle
moment où les peuples palestinien et
libanais sont massacrés à beyrouth par
l'armée israélienne que l'organisation
de libération de la palestine s'élèvent
contre toute violence aveugle fin de
citation
le premier ministre monsieur pierre
mauroy s'est également rendue rue des
rosiers en début d'après midi pierre
mauroy il ya fait une très belle décline
déclaration vous allez l'entendre
maintenant les éléments criminels ont
frappé à mort dans ce quartier au coeur
de paris je suis venu pour au nom du
gouvernement et en mon nom personnel
maclean et demont les victimes assurer
de notre soutien et de notre sympathie
des proches et l'ensemble de la
communauté juive communauté juive ici
dans le quartier dit beaucoup que c'est
à cause de votre politique séjournait en
arrive en plein paris la france veut la
paix partout dans le monde et elle
n'accepte pas que le sang innocent soit
ainsi versé le gouvernement mettra tout
en oeuvre pour arrêter les coupables
et pour assurer la protection des
citoyens d'autres ministres du
gouvernement de monsieur pierre mauroy
se sont donc rendus rue des rosiers
notamment monsieur badinter et monsieur
question de faire le miz de l'intérieur
qui était quelque peu malmené par un
groupe de manifestants
écoutez la réaction après cet attentat
la violence est toujours inadmissible en
politique vous un pays comme la france
qui est une démocratie dans lequel
chacun peut s'exprimer est absolument
intolérable le meurtre
l'assassinât le sang de victimes
innocentes qui coule est un spectacle
qui n'a pas sa place dans notre pays
tout sera mis en oeuvre pour découvrir
des auteurs de cet attentat la police
est déjà intervenue puisque des
inspecteurs qui était près des lieux de
l'attentât se sont porté immédiatement à
l'endroit la fusillade avait éclaté
l'un d'eux à d'ailleurs été blessés le
gouvernement s'emploiera avec toute
l'énergie dont il est capable
à découvrir les coupables unanimité dans
les réactions de condamnation je vous
disais tout à l'heure des partis
politiques français de la ligue des
droits de l'homme des syndicats monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing a exprimé sa
solidarité fraternelle vis-à-vis des
victimes de cette odieuse violence
monsieur jacques chirac maire de paris
exprime ses sentiments de profonde
affliction fige aussi jacques chirac
paris est devenu le champ clos de tous
les terrorismes cette situation
intolérable ne peut à l'évidence durée
je renouvelle avec la plus grande
vigueur
l'appel que j'ai déjà lancé à plusieurs
reprises pour que la sécurité des
parisiens et les parisiennes soit
assurée fin de citation
et puis l'ambassade d'israël en france
par la voix de monsieur scheirs ministre
plénipotentiaire a rappelé les
différents actes de terrorisme dont sont
l'objet les cibles israéliennes juives
en france
je ne pense pas qu'il ait un lien direct
avec ce qui se passe à beyrouth mais il
a certainement un lien avec la
représentation tendancieuse des
événements du liban depuis plusieurs
semaines depuis deux mois maintenant qui
au lieu de montrer qu'israël a engagé
une action afin
débarrasser la région le liban et
beyrouth de ce cancer afin de démanteler
l'organisation terroriste qui s'y
implanter sur le dos du peuple libanais
au lieu de cela on a mis israël en
accusation et cela constitue à
proprement parler une invitation un
appel aux pogroms une atmosphère
anti-israéliennes règne à paris c'est du
moins l'une des phrases du communiqué
publié à jérusalem par ministère des
affaires étrangères l'atmosphère anti
israélienne depuis le début de la guerre
au liban est particulièrement l'attitude
des médias français ajoute-t-on à
jérusalem encourage les organisations
extrémistes alors à jérusalem pour
antenne 2 jean marc il use a recueilli
les premières réactions pas cet attentat
dans la rue je suis pas tellement étonné
en fait depuis la guerre des six jours
même l'antisémitisme comme on dit
s'accentue va en s'accentuant maintenant
des paroles on passe aux actes
la réaction horrible
ses malheurs je ne comprends pas dans un
pays comme la france comme ça des gens
vivent paisiblement puis tout d'un coup
ils viennent ils tuent des gens d'autres
est-ce que ça c'est pas si la france est
restée la france comme avant c'est une
vrai sens je ne peux pas comprendre qu
est-ce que c'est parce que vous êtes
surpris avec la position de la france et
son attitude visé d'israël jeu je trouve
que ces attentats sont pas justifiées
mais s'explique par la position de la
france vis à vis d'israël veut que le
monnyer a fait ce programme l'ami de
mitterrand et
les juifs apparaître sont plus en
sécurité le bon vieux vu la politique
suivie par la france de ces derniers
temps devra peut-être qu'on s'attendait
en place il y à quelques minutes le
président de la république monsieur
françois mitterrand s'est rendu rue
pavée rue des rosiers et lieu cet
attentat ce midi président de la
république avait souhaité très
rapidement se rendre dans une synagogue
ce soir vous allez voir l'arrivée du
président françois mitterrand
cette synagogue de la rue pavée
président de la république qui a été
accueilli aux cris de mitterrand
trahison par quelques centaines de
manifestants ont regroupé derrière des
barrages de police une quinzaine de
mètres de l'entrée de la synagogue
monsieur mitterrand n'a fait aucune
déclaration
en entrant dans la synagogue la
cérémonie se poursuit actuellement
alors au delà des faits des statistiques
sèche aux riffs six morts 12 blessés
il ya toutes ces réactions vives
agressive la réaction contre la presse
mais est il possible derrière benyamine
d'aller un petit peu plus loin que ces
faits et de tenter d'expliquer quelque
chose avec l'au delà de l'horreur que
nous inspire cet entretien je crois
qu'il faut faire ce soir 2-3 remarque
d'abord des hommes et des femmes ont été
tuées aujourd'hui parce qu'ils étaient
juifs et uniquement pour ça nous avions
déjà connu ce genre de drames en france
en particulier il ya deux ans lors de
l'attentât de la rue copernic
aujourd'hui c'est dans la rue qu'on est
allé les chercher pour les abattre dans
leur quartier
nous sommes bien en face d'un acte
d'antisémitisme clair et net
ignoble de lâcheté qu'on ne vienne
surtout pas nous parler dans ce cas
d'actions terroristes habib politique
la deuxième chose qu'on peut remarquer
ce sont vous le disais tout à l'heure
kloet les accusations entre la
télévision et la manière dont elle rend
compte de la guerre au liban qui ont
immédiatement jaillit parmi un certain
nombre de personnes présentes sur les
lieux de l'attentât
alors ne s'agit pas ce soir d'engager
une polémique mais la seule réponse que
nous pouvons avancer est la suivante
nous essayons de faire notre métier sans
passion avec honnêteté et même lorsque
l'événement que nous rapportons n'est
pas à proprement parler
facile à regarder c'est notre devoir
tout de même que de vous informer et de
vous faire réfléchir
c'est précisément ce que nous avons fait
je crois depuis le début de la guerre au
liban
c'est ce que nous avons toujours fait
que ce soit au salvador en iran que
pour le massacre des enfants à mayotte
c'est ce que nous continuerons à faire
demain partout dans le monde où quelque
chose se produira nous ne choisissons
pas les faits nous ne faisons que
témoigner et ce n'est pas parce que nous
avons montré en un temps de terribles
images de bombardements américains sur
le nord vietnam que des tueurs fous ont
jamais pris pour cible des français
soupçonnés de sympathie pour la
politique américaine de l'éthique de
l'époque
la troisième chose enfin c'est une
question que l'on devra se poser à un
moment donné ou un autre à qui profite
le crime
certainement pas à la paix en tout cas
au moment où l'on entrevoyait justement
une lueur d'espoir pour un règlement de
la guerre au liban
merci bernard voilà ce que nous pouvions
dire ce que nous pouvions vous montrer
ce que nous pouvions tenté d expliquer
sur cet attentat qui a donc fait six
morts et douze blessés qui pour
l'instant n'a pas été revendiqué
fermement au liban où une seat une
solution diplomatique n'a jamais été
aussi proche bien les négociations
progressent sur le départ des
combattants palestiniens et l'arrivée
d'une force multinationale composé
notamment de soldats français
israël maintient sa position militaire
aujourd'hui encore une série de
bombardements à beyrouth notre envoyé
spécial philippe gassot témoigne leur
téléphone l'action avec des chasseurs
bombardiers
encore une journée que la population à
passer dans les abris quand vous prêtez
à bessan lumière uniquement quelques
rares bruit des enfants les enfants
partent tous les âges limites et une
odeur effrayant les pères et les mères
de famille rien pourtant à part une
couverture posée sur le sol parfois un
vrai jouet pétrole ont complètement
démunis qu'ils veulent maintenant et que
la guerre tard est-ce que les
bombardements ont leur cave
le père de 21 enfants au revoir le
soleil
l'information à la radio pour écouter
passionnément et la question qui devait
déposer tout l'après midi était de
savoir s'il était vrai que l'état
français elle est arrivée à beyrouth
en attendant l'évolution des
palestiniens de l'amour est laid camp de
chatila au ralenti dans le noir en
écoutant actuellement intégré les avions
à réaction
en france l'actualité politique c'est
bien sûr les suite de l'élection d'hier
en corse les 61 61 élus à l'assemblée de
corse sont désormais connus les
résultats officiels après contrôle
seront proclamés demain et l'assemblée
de corse peut ainsi je crois être
décomposé vous allez voir une liste à
droite 19 rpr udf bonapartiste avec
comme tête de liste monsieur jean paul
de rocca serra 6 usurpé giscardien
conduit par monsieur josé rossi et puis
4 divers droite à gauche bien il ya sept
communiste de lys monsieur dominique
bucchini trois socialistes plus un
socialiste dissident ont émergé répartis
géographiquement si on peut dire au nord
7 et au sud 4 et puis deux divers gauche
et puis et c'est la grande nouveauté
enfin sept élus autonomistes upc dans le
chef de file de monsieur edmond simeoni
et puis un nationaliste de gauche voilà
pour la répartition politique de cette
assemblée la première du genre élus à la
proportionnelle
alors tout de suite quelles sont les
leçons de cette élection quels en sont
les vainqueurs où les vaincus en corse
pour l'antenne de philippe harrouard
le vainqueur de cette élection c'est
l'assemblée régionale corse
elle est élue élections sans problème
avec un nombre confortable des lecteurs
sans passion c'est vrai mais sans ce
folklore un peu violent que l'on trouve
parfois dans des consultations sur ce
point les corses ont fait preuve de
maturité politique pour voulu dire les
électeurs des choses un peu
contradictoires d'une part ils n'ont pas
voulu remettre en cause le système des
clans en élisant monsieur de rocca serra
qui menait une liste d'opposition et qui
fait le meilleur score
mais l'autre point à la percée denman
simeoni 7 sièges montre bien que son
combat farouche contre les plans
justement a suscité un intérêt dans la
population surtout sur les jeunes sans
doute est peut-être un tournant pour
l'avenir
eh bien écoutez al'inverse des chefs de
clans j'appartiens à un mouvement qui a
des instances démocratiques qui vont se
réunir le samedi 14 août pour tirer la
leçon du scrutin
mais en toute hypothèse je dois déjà
dire que nous voulons absolument abattre
politiquement les deux chefs de clans et
que nous voulons lutter contre une
politique d'assistance d'aliénation qui
a conduit la corse pour un véritable
point de déchéance économique sociale
culturelle et morale
je n'ai pas le sentiment que l'on puisse
non qualifiés de clan et ensuite je
pourrai dire que les petites listes
aussi sont en fait une addition de
petits clans familiaux car les 61
candidats de chaque liste
on essayait d'attirer des suffrages
je ne dis pas que c'était l'essentiel
mais cela a une influence non
négligeable dans le succès des candidats
d'une des petites listes
à l'heure actuelle personne n'est
capable de dire qui sera élu le
président de l'assemblée corse le 20
août
ici les hommes comptent plus que les
clivages politiques traditionnels
et ce n'est pas dans le calcul
mathématique droite gauche que l'on
trouvera la solution les négociations
souterraines sont commencés et il n'est
pas dans la confidence a bien des
chances de s'y perdre
donc le scrutin ouvre plusieurs
inconnues sur l'élection du président et
puis sur la façon dont cette assemblée
sera capable de gérer les affaires de
l'île
disons que le pari régional n'est pas
encore gagné mais une première étape a
été franchie c'est certain
le pays subit notre organisation en
régionaliste que des organisations
bretonne se sont réjouis du succès
autonomistes le parti socialiste voit un
échec de la droite mais selon le
dirigeant socialiste le ps lui souffre
dans l'île de sa récente implantation
aggravée par des divisions locales dans
ses rangs monsieur gaston defferre le
miz l'intérieur expliquait celui des
antennes de me dis que c'est une
victoire des corses pour eux mêmes les
corses ont compris et approuve ce que
leur proposait le gouvernement déclarait
donc ce matin monsieur de fer suite des
réactions celle du émergé avec son
président roger gérard schwartzenberg
et tout d'abord écouter celle de
monsieur jacques chirac le président du
rpr enregistré ce matin encore est
satisfaction de voir les listes les cinq
listes de l'opposition obtenir un score
très remarquable 46% des voix 29 sièges
et la liste générale de l'opposition
arrivé très largement tente ensuite un
recul très important des partis de
l'actuelle majorité mrg socialistes
communistes officielle et dissidents qui
au total font si les chiffres sont
exacts de l'ordre de 38% avec 23 sièges
et enfin l'arrivée de l'union du peuple
corse qui représente aucune force sur le
plan politique corse mais ma deuxième
observation concerne les conséquences
des effets nocifs du scrutin
proportionnel même s'il est apparemment
le plus juste car en effet il est
aujourd'hui pratiquement impossible de
constituer une majorité homogène
susceptible de gouverner les affaires
régionales de la corse
ce vote a une double signification en
votant pour les radicaux de gauche les
électeurs corses ont voulu voter pour un
parti qui agit pour la pleine mise en
valeur de l'identité corse dans le cadre
de l'unité nationale et ils ont voté
aussi pour un parti qui est à la fois
pour les solutions de progrès et de
raison de réalisme je vois là en tout
cas la confirmation de l'importante est
nécessaire contribution du troisième
courant de la gauche à la majorité
présidentielle
car s'il n'y avait eu dimanche soir hier
soir que simplement le pc et le ps
présente aux élections aux corses
cela aurait représenté pour la gauche un
déficit de 19 % des voix
ce que réalise pour sa part le mouvement
des radicaux de gauche c'est assez dire
que la gauche ce n'est pas une majorité
bicolore un simple tandem pc ps c'est
une majorité très pierre avec son
troisième pilier le mouvement des
radicaux de gauche
brièvement je vous rappelle
l'information économique de cette
journée c'est le dollar qui vaut un peu
plus de cette france 7 francs 0,5 à
paris sur la place aujourd'hui c'est le
plus haut niveau jamais atteint par le
dollar
alors avant d'achever ce journal avec
alain gillot-pétré les prévisions
météorologiques une bonne nouvelle elle
concerne la santé de didier pironi le
pilote français été opéré du bras gauche
et les médecins se disent plutôt
optimiste maintenant le temps pour
demain nous aurons demain un certain
mieux pour ne pas dire un mieux certains
davantage d'éclaircies qu'aujourd'hui
regardant la photo satellite de 14h30
voici au sud du pays il faisait beau en
corse aussi sur les côtes de la manche
également
et sur la moitié nord du pays tous ces
nuages on les expliquent très facilement
et gaz de l'air froid ici il ya de l'air
chaud là au contact des 2 secret des
nuages c'est le même type de temps pour
demain car toutes ses lignes de nuages
là ondulent sur l'europe comme ceci donc
pour demain la carte vous dire mieux
qu'un long discours qui va se passer
voilà sur la méditerranée c'est du beau
temps beaucoup d'éclaircies même très
très peu de nuages quasiment pas
dirais-je au sud de la loire des brumes
le matin de belgique merci l'après midi
au nord de la loire un peu moins
d'éclaircies plus de nuage après
dissipation des brumes mais il y aura
davantage d'éclaircies qu'aujourd'hui
sur la manche
hélas je crains qu'il n'y a encore pas
mal de nuages mais tout de même on peut
espérer quelques rayons de soleil les
températures pour demain sont en hausse
sa baisse à monde sans arrêt en ce
moment ça monde demain minimum 19 degrés
à cherbourg maximum 29° à marseille et
nîmes moyenne nationale 24° c'était 22
degrés
aujourd'hui donc ça monte c'est presque
l'été demain c'est le mardi
6 août trois minutes de soleil en moins
levé 6h37 coucher 21h14 c'est la
ceinture donné que le patron des
cordonniers
on n'a pas tellement le coeur à rire
aujourd'hui mais c'est quand même de mal
à saint laurent alors bonne fête laurent
broomhead merci à la je vous rappelle
donc l'information de cette journée ce
midi il était un peu plus de 13 heures
parce que dans le quartier de la rue des
rosiers le quartier de 4e arrondissement
de paris que vous découvrez sur cette
carte
deux hommes ont perpétré un attentat
antisémite il a eu six morts et douze
blessés
monsieur françois mitterrand s'est rendu
il ya quelques minutes dans une
synagogue pour assister à un office il y
a eu des bousculades et des cris contre
les différents ministres du gouvernement
de monsieur mouvoir et contre monsieur
mitterrand jean louis dawson à zéro
heure trente vous donnera les dernières
informations de cette journée pour un
parc vous retrouverez demain
bonsoir